up until last week it was thought this
parliamentary meeting could have been
the setting for a showdown between the
malaysian government
and the opposition the new prime
minister mouridin yassin
and several mps left the governing
coalition in february
triggering a collapse of the previous
government the prime minister at that
time mahathir mohammad resigned
refusing to work with the new alliance
which would have included the united
malays national organization
a party that was defeated in the last
election amid a string of corruption
allegations
earlier this month mahathir who says he
still has majority support
proposed a motion of no confidence
against the prime minister
but the government has limited the
agenda to just the king's
opening speech citing efforts to contain
the spread of the coronavirus
during the last february we are without
the government for
two weeks and we have lost two precious
weeks
in terms of lockdown or in terms of
strategy how to combat this pandemic
so i support the government decision
to limit a one day sitting of parliament
just to avoid
any excessive politicking among the
politicians
opposition politicians accused the prime
minister of being afraid of a
no-confidence vote
we cannot accept the excuse that we can
only meet for two hours because of the
coronavirus pandemic
had postponed the original parliament
session from march 9th
eight days after he was sworn in as
prime minister
analysts say he's been shoring up
support since
the prime minister keeps his coalition
partners loyal by rewarding them with
political powers
for example the chief minister positions
in the state of johor and malacca
mps have also been appointed to
important positions in government-linked
companies
or made special envoys over the weekend
parties in the governing alliance said
they would formalize their lose
coalition
the next parliament sitting will take
place in july
and with the speaker of the lower house
having accepted a proposal for a
no-confidence motion
against the prime minister it is
expected that a showdown can still take
place in parliament later this year
malaysia's political drama is far from
over
florence louis al jazeera kuala lumpur